En la clase de hoy quiero, de
cierta forma, hacer un cambio
de lo que hemos estado hablando en
la primera unidad del curso.
Como saben, la primera unidad del
curso estaba enfocada en un
conjunto de textos que abordaban el
tema de la prosperidad humana.
Aunque nuestro primer texto,
el reto de Glaucón
de La República de Platón, se
ocupaba de la moralidad
y de cómo contribuía a la
prosperidad humana, hasta ahora,
no hemos prestado mucha atención a lo
que han dicho los filósofos
sobre la naturaleza de la moralidad.
El objetivo de esta unidad es,
de forma muy rápida,
presentarles hoy y el próximo martes las
2 principales teorías morales
de la tradición occidental, y en
el resto de las sesiones,
antes de las vacaciones de
marzo, hablaremos
de la investigación empírica
de estas cuestiones.
Sé que en esta clase tenemos
formaciones diversas.
Algunos están tomando su
primer curso de filosofía.
Algunos ya han tomado un
curso entero de ética.
Por eso, he intentado armar
esta clase de tal forma
que funcione bien para otros y espero
que no sea aburrida para quienes ya
han visto este tema antes.
Para compensar que hay muy
poca psicología
empírica en esta clase, he preparado 6
diapositivas con votaciones.
Están a mitad de la clase, justo
cuando todos estén quedándose dormidos
porque anoche durmieron solo 2 horas.
Aunque no pongan atención
en la primera parte,
podrán votar a la mitad.
¿De qué se trata la filosofía moral?
¿Qué significa dar una explicación
filosófica de la moralidad?
La filosofía moral es un intento
sistemático para entender los
conceptos morales y para justificar los
principios y las teorías morales.
Es decir, la filosofía moral, aunque
termine dando una respuesta
no sistemática de cómo funciona
la moralidad y qué hace,
intenta responder desde un
pensamiento sistemático
sobre la naturaleza de la moralidad.
¿A qué me refiero con moralidad?
Me refiero a que las teorías morales
intentan explicar términos
como "correcto" e "incorrecto",
"aceptable" e "inaceptable",
"deber" y "no deber", "prohibido",
"bueno", "malo" y cosas por el estilo,
e intentan explicar los
comportamientos sujetos a esos
términos.
Básicamente, para recordarles una
distinción terminológica
que hemos hecho antes, es
una acción normativa
a diferencia de una descriptiva.
La teoría moral filosófica
no pretende decirnos
cómo actúan las personas.
Busca decirnos cómo deberían actuar
si desean ajustarse a las limitaciones
que la moralidad les impone.
En especial, la filosofía moral
está interesada en proporcionar
una respuesta con principios a
3 tipos de preguntas.
El primer tipo de pregunta lo encontramos
en el texto del reto de Glaucón.
Es la cuestión de la motivación moral.
"¿Por qué querríamos actuar
según lo que nos exige la moralidad?".
En un momento, les daré una idea
del tipo de respuestas
que se han dado a esa pregunta.
La primera pregunta de la
filosofía moral es:
¿Por qué queremos ser morales?
Y la segunda es:
"¿Qué deberíamos hacer si
queremos actuar moralmente?".
Hemos hablado muy poco de
esto hasta el momento.
Sabemos que según
Aristóteles, para ser
valientes,
tenemos que actuar como los valientes.
Pero Aristóteles
clasificó la valentía
como una virtud sin más explicación
y clasificó la cobardía como un vicio
sin más explicación que el análisis
muy general del punto medio.
Y no hemos visto ninguna
afirmación específica
sobre acciones particulares que sean
moralmente aceptables o no.
La segunda cosa que intenta
hacer la teoría moral es
-les daré ejemplos más adelante-
darnos respuestas
específicas a la pregunta:
"¿Esta acción es
correcta moralmente?".
Además, una teoría
moral busca decirnos
por qué dimos las respuestas que
dimos en la segunda pregunta.
"¿En virtud de qué rasgo en común
estas acciones se
clasifican como morales
y se distinguen de las
acciones inmorales?".
¿Cómo son las respuestas a
estas tres preguntas?
Como ya la hemos visto antes,
comencemos con la pregunta de
la motivación moral.
Una categoría de respuestas que
podríamos dar a por qué
queremos ser morales y actuar según las
limitaciones de la moralidad,
es una explicación de interés propio.
Podríamos dar esta explicación:
cuando se comportan moralmente,
las cosas salen bien.
Como Sócrates argumenta
respondiendo a Glaucón,
cuando se comportan siguiendo las
limitaciones de la moralidad,
su alma está en armonía.
Y eso les proporciona la posibilidad
de cierto tipo de prosperidad.
O podrían tener lo que está
implícito en el primer argumento
que Glaucón da, la visión
de que la moralidad
proporciona cierto tipo de
estabilidad en la sociedad.
Si nosotros nos comportamos
de forma prosocial
aumenta la posibilidad de que
quienes nos rodean
se comporten igual.
Y alcanzamos un tipo de
estado de equilibrio
en el que las cosas salen bien
si todos se comportan de
forma prosocial.
Retomaremos este tema
al comienzo de la sección de
filosofía política.
Un tipo de teoría del interés
que apela a cierto tipo
de coordinación,
ya sea entre las partes del alma o entre
los individuos de una sociedad.
Un segundo tipo de teoría del interés
es lo que llamaríamos
"conseguir cosas buenas".
Esto se encuentra en el corazón de
algunas tradiciones religiosas.
Si actúan según las
limitaciones de la moralidad,
obtienen vida eterna en un
lugar maravilloso.
Si no actúan
según las limitaciones de la moralidad,
obtienen vida eterna en un
lugar horrible.
La idea de que hay una recompensa
más allá de la tierra
por comportarse moralmente
es un ejemplo de una justificación
interesada de la moralidad.
O podríamos dar una justificación
como la de Adimanto ante el
reto de Glaucón.
Adimanto destaca que la moralidad
les proporciona una reputación
elevada, entre otras cosas.
Como resultado de comportarse
según los estándares de la moralidad,
su comportamiento es
percibido de esa forma
y esa reputación les brinda un valor.
O podría ser, como Aristóteles
discute al final del Libro X,
que la sociedad está
estructurada de tal forma
que motiva a la gente a actuar
según las imitaciones
de la moralidad porque al
hacerlo se evita el castigo.
Muchos respetamos los
límites de velocidad
precisamente por eso.
Los respetamos especialmente si
vemos alguna patrulla cerca.
Pero también podemos tener una
versión interiorizada
de la reducción del castigo.
Parte del concepto freudiano
que vimos en la clase
del alma dividida abordaba el
desarrollo de la conciencia
como una interiorización de
las reglas externas,
donde el superego se enoja
cuando el ello actúa
sin ajustarse a las
limitaciones morales.
También podríamos tener una
versión no freudiana
que apele a la noción de la conciencia.
La idea de que la
moralidad nos proporciona
la posibilidad de salvación, o
una reputación elevada,
o la posibilidad de evitar el
castigo de las leyes externas
o de la propia conciencia
es otra versión de la
teoría del interés.
Ese es un tipo de justificación
que podríamos dar para
comportarnos moralmente.
Una segunda justificación muy distinta
dice que actuamos moralmente
porque los rasgos normativos
son rasgos fundamentales del mundo.
Hay un "deber" inconsciente en el mundo.
Es un hecho de la realidad
que estamos obligados
a actuar de cualquier forma que
nos lo exija la moralidad,
no de forma interesada,
sino simplemente porque somos
sensibles a ese rasgo del mundo,
tenemos motivación para
actuar moralmente.
Una tercera justificación
de la motivación
es lo que llamaríamos una teoría
de la capacidad de acción,
que dice a grandes rasgos que la
gente es así simplemente.
Las explicaciones
evolucionistas que dicen
que los comportamientos
prosociales han sido
seleccionados,
tal vez porque permiten la solución
de problemas de coordinación.
Sin importar la explicación,
esta teoría afirma que el comportamiento
prosocial ha sido seleccionado.
Es un hecho inconsciente del mundo que
actuemos de forma prosocial;
no es un hecho normativo
inconsciente del mundo,
sino un hecho descriptivo
inconsciente que nos comportemos
así.
O podrían tener, una versión no
basada en la evolución,
sino que considerara
que solo es la forma de
expresarse del alma humana
cuando se ajusta a su estado natural.
Podrían tener una teoría de
moralidad que dijera
que la razón para comportarse
moralmente es de interés propio.
Podrían tener una teoría de
moralidad que dijera
que la razón para comportarse
moralmente es por altruismo.
Podrían tener una teoría de
moralidad que dijera que la razón
para comportarse moralmente es porque
es así como nos comportamos.
O podrían tener una teoría combinada.
Ya hemos hablado de la primera teoría,
la teoría del interés propio.
A lo largo de esta sección del curso,
hablaremos sobre los otros
tipos de explicaciones.
Esos son algunos ejemplos de
los tipos de respuestas
que se dan a la primera pregunta
sobre la motivación moral.
¿Qué tipos de temas surgen
cuando pensamos en el
comportamiento moral?
Vieron varios ejemplos de esto
en las lecturas para hoy.
Una de las preguntas que las teorías
morales intentan responder
es la cuestión de si es
moralmente necesario
o está moralmente permitido
lastimar a una persona por el
bien de muchas otras.
Como en la historia de Bernard
William, sobre Jim y los indios,
donde Jim se enfrenta a un problema:
si está dispuesto a disparar a 1
de los 20 prisioneros,
los otros 19 se dejarán en libertad;
pero si no está dispuesto a
disparar a 1, los 20 morirán.
O el cuento de Omelas, que nos narra
la historia de una sociedad
cuya prosperidad depende del
sufrimiento de un solo niño.
O los casos del tranvía que les
presenté en primera clase,
donde un tranvía se dirige
hacia 5 personas
y nosotros podemos desviarlo
para que solo muera una persona y no 5.
Esos son algunos ejemplos de
representaciones esquemáticas
de los tipos de preguntas
a los que se enfrenta la teoría
moral todo el tiempo.
Este tipo de preguntas
surgen cuando pensamos en aplazar
una amenaza, por ejemplo,
¿es correcto poner en
cuarentena a una población
que padece una enfermedad
particular aunque esto podría
causarle daño, pero beneficiaría
al resto de la sociedad?
pensemos sobre este tipo de cuestiones.
Un tipo de pregunta que la
filosofía moral intenta responder
es si este tipo de sacrificio
es moralmente requerido o
moralmente permitido.
Una versión especialmente
profunda de esta pregunta
surge cuando pensamos en cuáles son
nuestros deberes morales hacia
los menos afortunados.
El filósofo Peter Singer ha
argumentado que toda la estructura
del primer mundo y el tercer mundo
es ilegítima moralmente
porque implica una falta de voluntad
por parte del primer mundo
para hacer lo que se le
exige moralmente:
tomar una gran parte de sus recursos y
redistribuirlos entre aquellos
que están padeciendo enfermedades que
fácilmente podrían curarse.
La gente que no tiene mosquiteros,
que no tiene vacunas,
que no tiene agua potable,
que no cuenta con la atención médica
durante sus primeros 5 años,
que podría ayudar a
prevenir la ceguera.
Otra pregunta que plantea
la teoría moral,
que de cierta forma es una versión
de la pregunta anterior, es:
¿Cuáles son nuestras obligaciones
hacia los menos afortunados?
También plantea preguntas como estas:
¿Este tipo de comportamientos son
obligatorios moralmente?
¿Es una obligación moral
comportarnos de formas
que ayuden al medio ambiente, por
ejemplo, que reciclemos?
¿Es moralmente obligatorio que
actuemos de cierta forma
con los animales no humanos, tal
vez siendo vegetarianos?
¿Se nos exige moralmente que
adoremos a algún Dios?
¿El culto religioso es algo
moralmente obligatorio?
¿El respeto a los mayores,
una parte fundamental
de los marcos morales tradicionales,
es moralmente obligatorio?
Las teorías morales también
plantean preguntas como estas:
¿Este tipo de cosas están
permitidas moralmente?
¿El aborto está permitido moralmente?
¿La eutanasia está
permitida moralmente? ¿
La pena de muerte está
permitida moralmente?
¿El sexo antes del matrimonio?
¿Mentir por una u otra motivación?
En nuestra próxima lectura,
veremos que Kant argumenta
que fracasar en el cultivo
de nuestros talentos
es una violación a los
mandatos morales.
Esas son el tipo de preguntas
que intentan responder las
teorías morales.
Parece ser un grupo
bastante heterogéneo.
Pero sirve para darles una idea
de la mayoría de explicaciones que
buscan dar las teorías morales.
Veamos las 4 teorías morales
principales en la tradición occidental
y pensemos cómo podrían
responder categóricamente
a este amplio rango de preguntas.
La teoría moral que abordaremos
principalmente en la clase de hoy
es el utilitarismo.
Esta teoría argumenta que
un acto es moral
en la medida en que produce el
mayor bien para la mayoría.
Su noción fundamental es la
noción del bien.
Y nos da respuestas a las preguntas
que planteamos previamente
siempre que conozcamos
cómo se distribuyen los bienes
en respuesta a ellas.
Si sabemos qué es lo que produce la
felicidad en los seres sensibles,
entonces el utilitarismo
responderá a la pregunta
de si ser vegetariano es
un mandato moral.
Nos dice que tomemos la
cantidad de felicidad
distribuida entre los seres sensibles
y que veamos cuál distribución
maximizará la cantidad de felicidad.
El utilitarismo nos da
un tipo de respuesta
sistemática a esta pregunta.
Un segundo tipo de
respuesta a esta pregunta,
que discutiremos en la clase del martes,
es lo que dicen Kant y la
tradición deontológica.
Kant dice que un acto es moral
en la medida en que se realice
como resultado de actuar
con el tipo correcto de motivación.
Su principal noción no es lo bueno,
sino lo correcto.
Con base en esto, Kant dará un
montón de respuestas
a nuestras preguntas específicas.
En particular, argumentará
que no es correcto
sacrificar el bien de uno por
el bien de la mayoría.
Dirá que mentir es
moralmente inaceptable.
En la próxima clase veremos
cómo a partir de un principio
abstracto como este
podemos derivar este tipo de
respuestas particulares.
Ya hemos visto la respuesta
tradicional antigua de Aristóteles,
de que un acto es moral en la
medida en que se realice
como resultado de tener un
carácter virtuoso.
Aristóteles nos dice que veamos
cómo se comportaría una
persona bien educada.
Cuando hayamos visto cómo se
porta una persona virtuosa,
aprenderemos de su ejemplo qué es lo
que la moralidad nos exige.
Por último, una tradición de la
que no hablaremos mucho
en esta clase es, por supuesto, una
base moral que se ha mantenido
en el centro de la cultura occidental
durante los últimos 2000 años,
me refiero a la idea de que un
acto es moral en la medida
en que se ajusta a lo que nos
exige una divinidad.
Podemos dar una explicación,
como los utilitarios,
que apele a la noción del bien.
Podemos dar una justificación que
apele, como la deontología,
a la noción de lo correcto.
Podemos dar una justificación que apele,
como la ética de las virtudes,
a la noción de la virtuosidad.
O podemos dar una justificación que
apele, como la ética religiosa,
a la noción del mandato divino.
Analicemos un poco más
la relación entre estas 3
teorías en particular,
en las que nos vamos a
enfocar en esta clase,
como una forma de entender la
teoría particular
que abordamos hoy,
concretamente el
utilitarismo.
La ética de las virtudes centra
su atención en el actor,
no en la persona que está
en un escenario
y recita las líneas de Hamlet,
sino el actor que realiza un
acto que será moral o no.
La deontología centra su
atención en el acto.
No se fija en quién lo hace,
sino en qué acto se hace y
bajo qué descripción.
Por el contrario, el
consecuencialismo, no se fija
en quién realiza el acto ni en la
descripción bajo la cual se realiza,
sino en las consecuencias que produce.
Y nos hemos topado con la
teoría de la virtud
-veamos si reconocen a este
caballero- en voz de Aristóteles.
Veremos la deontología en
voz de Immanuel Kant.
Hoy discutiremos el consecuencialismo y,
en particular, el utilitarismo en
voz de John Stuart Mill.
Veamos qué dice Mill
sobre la naturaleza
fundamental de la moralidad.
Mill sostiene que...
por cierto, ya vamos a llegar la
diapositiva de votación,
así que si se están quedando dormidos,
llegó el momento de sacar sus clickers.
Dentro de 4 o 5 minutos
tendremos algunas encuestas.
Mill sostiene que el marco
correcto para analizar
las teorías morales es el
del consecuencialismo,
que no se fija en el actor como
la teoría de la virtud,
que no se fija en el acto
como la deontología,
sino que se fija en las consecuencias
como el consecuencialismo.
El grado de rectitud moral de un acto
se determina según sus consecuencias.
Mill proporciona una versión
particular de esto.
Dice que el grado de rectitud
moral de un acto se determina
por un tipo de
consecuencia en
particular,
concretamente la utilidad
que produce el acto.
Podrían tener una teoría
consecuencialista que dijera
que el grado de rectitud
moral de un acto
se determina por sus
consecuencias, por ejemplo,
por la cantidad de
plátanos que produce.
Sería una teoría rara,
pero sería una teoría
consecuencialista que dice que el
grado de
rectitud moral de un acto está
determinado por sus consecuencias,
en particular por su grado de
producción de plátanos.
Sería un tipo muy general de
teoría consecuencialista.
Las teorías utilitarias son un tipo
particular de teorías consecuencialistas
que dicen que el grado de
rectitud moral de un acto
está determinado por sus consecuencias,
en particular,
por la cantidad de utilidad que produce,
o felicidad en la versión de Mill.
Es decir, recuerden los apuntes
que obtuvieron esta semana
en la sección, que para ser utilitario,
ser consecuencialista es una condición
suficiente, pero no necesaria.
Y para ser consecuencialista,
ser utilitario es una condición
necesaria, pero no suficiente.
Si lo que acabo de decir no
les parece obvio,
vean la segunda parte de los apuntes
que obtuvieron esta semana
en la sección.
Mill no solo hace un
compromiso utilitario,
en realidad, en el curso de
dicho compromiso
hace dos afirmaciones muy
particulares, sobre las que quiero
que me den su opinión en
algunos casos específicos.
La primera es la famosa fórmula del
principio de la mayor felicidad,
que en sus textos está justo al inicio de
la página 77 de la reimpresión.
Mill dice: "las acciones son correctas
en la medida en que tienden a promover
la felicidad, e incorrectas
lo inverso a la felicidad".
Unas páginas más adelante
aclara que no se refiere
a la propia felicidad del agente, sino
a la de todos los interesados.
En un momento analizaremos
lo que eso implica.
El segundo compromiso de Mill
que quiero que analicen
es uno que va directamente en contra
de lo que hablamos la semana
pasada sobre Aristóteles.
Mill dice que el motivo no
tiene nada que ver
con la moralidad de la acción.
"Quien salva a otra persona
de ahogarse hace lo
que es moralmente correcto, sin
importar si su motivo es el deber
o la esperanza de que le paguen".
Mill dice que la motivación con
la que se realiza un acto
no nos indica nada sobre la
moralidad del acto.
No niega que nos diga algo
sobre el actor.
Se conforma con decir que
alguien que actúa
con la esperanza de que le paguen es,
de cierta forma, distinto a alguien
que actúa por un sentido de
deber u obligación moral.
Pero en lo que respecta al valor
del acto en sí mismo,
Mill considera que no hay diferencia.
Esa es la primera pregunta
que les quería hacer.
Consideren el caso que describe Mill.
Ven que alguien se está
ahogando en un lago.
Y la pregunta es:
¿Su acción de salvar a esa
persona es moralmente correcta
o virtuosa solo si se hace porque
se considera un deber?
Quiero salvar a esa persona
porque es lo correcto
o por cualquier otro motivo prosocial.
Pulsen 1 si piensan así.
¿O el acto es correcto moralmente
sin importar el motivo?
Incluso si lo hacen porque hay un
cartel que dice: "Recompensa
por salvar a una persona que se
está ahogando: 10,000 USD".
Y entonces piensan: "10,000 USD es
una buena cantidad de dinero".
Y se avientan al agua.
Bien. Empiezan los 10
segundos del cronómetro.
Tenemos más o menos
50... 70 respuestas.
Empiezan a subir los números.
Veamos si por instinto este salón
está lleno de kantianos o
consecuencialistas.
Curiosamente, casi están empatados.
Muchos de ustedes parecen
coincidir con Mill en la idea
de que un acto es correcto
moralmente sin importar el motivo.
Pero una parte considerable de
ustedes estarán contentos
cuando leamos a Kant, quien nos da la
respuesta que ustedes dieron.
En la sección de la siguiente semana
podrán dialogar entre ustedes,
los que están de un lado con
los que están del otro,
para explicarse por qué están
dentro de un grupo o del otro.
Por ahora, Mill va bastante bien.
Tiene a una pequeña
mayoría de su lado.
Ahora quiero presentarles una serie
de casos para preguntarles
qué piensan acerca del principio
de la mayor felicidad.
Recuerden, Mill dice que
un acto es moral
en la medida en que produce la mayor
felicidad para la mayoría,
pero no nos interesa
cómo se distribuye dicha
felicidad entre los individuos.
Comencemos con el siguiente caso.
Pueden realizar una acción
y obtendrán 100 unidades de felicidad.
¿No se sienten prosociales
ante esas caritas felices de colores?
Cada carita feliz representa
10 unidades de felicidad.
Supongamos que tienen un ventilador.
Es un día muy caluroso
y tienen un ventilador que sopla
directo sobre ustedes.
La frescura del ventilador
les da 100 unidades de felicidad.
O supongamos que tienen unas
galletas deliciosas
y comerlas les da 100
unidades de felicidad.
Además, realizar esta acción
da a otras 100 personas
1 unidad de felicidad a cada una.
Supongamos que su ventilador sopla
un poco afuera de su cuarto,
además de refrescarlos a
ustedes, con 100 unidades,
refresca a los de otro cuarto,
con 1 unidad a cada uno.
O supongamos que cuando terminan
de comer sus 100 galletas,
sobran 100 galletas más, y otras
100 personas obtienen 1
cada quien y obtienen 1
unidad de felicidad.
Ok. Ese es el Acto 1.
Hay 200 unidades de felicidad en total.
Ustedes obtienen 100 unidades
y otras 100 personas
obtienen 1 unidad cada una.
Tienen la opción de hacer el Acto 1
o el Acto 2 que les voy a explicar.
En ambos, ustedes obtienen
el mismo efecto.
Obtienen 100 unidades de felicidad.
Aquí están ustedes con sus 100
unidades de felicidad.
En este caso, si cambiaran ligeramente
la posición de su ventilador,
estarían igual de frescos
que en el Acto 1.
Pero la gente de afuera
obtendría el doble de felicidad.
Mueven un poco el ventilador.
Y las otras personas
se refrescan 2 unidades en vez de 1.
O en vez de tirar las
galletas que sobran
después de comerse sus 100 galletas
y que la gente solo obtenga 1
unidad de felicidad,
dejan las otras galletas ahí
para que todos obtengan
2 unidades de felicidad.
En este caso, por hacer una acción
que no tiene consecuencias
distintas para ustedes en
cuanto a felicidad,
duplican la felicidad de otras 100
personas con respecto a la acción.
La pregunta simplemente es:
Entre el Acto 1,
que trae 200 unidades de felicidad,
100 para ustedes
y 1 para otras 100 personas,
o el Acto 2, que trae la misma
cantidad de felicidad para ustedes,
pero 200 unidades de
felicidad para los otros,
y por lo tanto 300 unidades en total,
pulsen 1 si piensan que solo
el Acto 1 es moral.
El Acto 1 donde de ustedes
obtienen 100 unidades
y todos los demás 1.
Pulsen 2 si piensan que solo
el Acto 2 es moral,
donde ustedes mueven un
poco su ventilador
o cualquier cosa que hagan
duplica la felicidad
de quienes los rodean, o pulsen 3,
si piensan que cualquiera de
estos actos es moral.
Ok. Voy a poner 10 segundos
en el cronómetro
para que veamos cómo resulta
su primer acercamiento
al principio de la mayor
felicidad de Mill.
Veamos los resultados.
Ok. Muy pocos consideran que
solo el Acto 1 es moral,
donde ustedes obtienen 100
unidades de felicidad
y otras 100 personas obtienen solo 1.
Pero están más o menos
empatados en la cuestión
de si la moralidad les exige que
redistribuyan sus recursos
para que también lleguen a los demás.
La mayor parte de nuestra discusión
en las siguientes diapositivas
se ocupará de ver si este
44% cambia de postura.
Me interesa ver cómo termina todo esto.
Ok. Ese fue nuestro primer caso,
donde sin costo para ustedes
pueden dar felicidad a los demás.
Ahora vamos a comparar el mismo Acto 1.
Ustedes obtienen 100
unidades de felicidad;
otras personas obtienen 1
unidad cada quien.
Hay en total 200 unidades. En el Acto 3,
ustedes tienen que restar 50
unidades a su felicidad
para redistribuir los bienes.
Al mover su ventilador
para que otras personas
obtengan 2 unidades cada una,
ustedes reducen un poco la cantidad
de utilidad que reciben.
Aun así sigue siendo más
beneficioso en general.
En el Acto 1, ustedes obtienen
100 unidades de felicidad;
las otras personas obtienen 1.
En el Acto 3, ustedes reducen su
felicidad, mueven su ventilador,
comen menos galletas, pero
redistribuyen los recursos
para que los demás obtengan 2 unidades.
Ok. ¿Cuál es moral? Solo el Acto 1,
donde ustedes obtienen 100 unidades
y todos los demás solo 1;
o solo el Acto 3, donde ustedes
obtienen 50 unidades y los demás 2,
pero el total es mayor; o
cualquiera de los 2.
Otra vez,
tenemos 10 segundos para votar.
Veamos los resultados.
Bien.
Cambió un poco la percepción de
moralidad de los actos.
Muchos piensan que es
necesario moralmente
aumentar la felicidad de
quienes los rodean
cuando no existe ningún
perjuicio para ustedes,
pero el porcentaje disminuye cuando
existe algún costo para ustedes.
Noten que Mill tiene claro que el
Acto 3 es moralmente requerido,
que solamente la acción que
trae la mayor cantidad
de utilidad a la comunidad es la
acción moralmente requerida.
Veamos un tercer caso.
El Acto 1 es el mismo que antes.
Ustedes obtienen 100 unidades.
Todos los demás obtienen 1 unidad.
Para hacer el bien a los demás,
ustedes tienen que disminuir
su propia utilidad.
Voltean por completo su ventilador.
Pero el resultado
es que otras 100 personas
obtienen 3 unidades cada quien.
La pregunta es:
¿Cuál está moralmente
permitido para ustedes?
El Acto 1 que presentamos primero
o el Acto 4, donde ustedes
perdían cierta utilidad
pero las otras personas la ganaban.
¿O ambos actos tienen el mismo valor?
Noten el total de 200
unidades o 250 unidades.
El Acto 1, nuestro caso clásico;
o el Acto 4 en el que ustedes
padecían cierta incomodidad.
Pero a cambio de esa incomodidad,
otras personas, no ustedes,
disfrutaban de algún bien.
Ok. Pongamos otra vez el
cronómetro de 10 segundos
y veamos los resultados.
Ok. En este caso,
parece que muy pocos de ustedes
están del lado de Mill.
Cierta cantidad de ustedes están aquí,
diciendo que necesitamos proporcionar
el mayor bien para la mayoría.
Y un porcentaje considerable de
ustedes comienza a pensar
que tal vez la moralidad no exige
sacrificio de su parte.
Continuemos. El siguiente caso es
exactamente igual que el anterior,
pero en este caso es alguien más
quien pierde 50 unidades
de utilidad para distribuir 3
unidades de utilidad a los demás.
Aquí está el caso.
Acto 1: ustedes obtienen 100 y
los otros 1 cada uno.
Hay 200 unidades en total.
O asumamos que ustedes conservan
sus 100 unidades de felicidad.
Los estamos dejando fuera
de la ecuación.
Y la pregunta es:
Supongamos que están
distribuyendo los recursos
para toda una sociedad.
En realidad, en este Acto 1
tendría que ser alguien más,
un caso donde alguien más tiene
100 unidades de felicidad
y los otros 100 obtienen 1
unidad cada quien;
o el Acto 5 donde alguien más
pierde 50 unidades de felicidad,
pero los otros 100 obtienen 3
unidades cada quien.
Vamos a reemplazarlos a ustedes en
el Acto 1 por alguien más
y elegir una distribución de
recursos en una sociedad:
la que produce 200 unidades de bien
o la que produce 250 unidades de bien
y una disminución de 50 unidades
que sufre una persona
a cambio de 300 unidades de
beneficios para los otros.
¿Cuál consideran que es
una exigencia moral?
5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Veamos si hay algún cambio con
respecto al caso pasado.
Ok. De repente, aquí obtenemos un
cambio radical en las gráficas.
Casi el 50% considera
que la acción que exige hacer
sufrir a una persona,
que implica una reducción de su
utilidad no es un mandato moral.
Más tarde en la sección,
veremos si existe
realmente un aspecto fijo
que determine una línea de base y
si este cambio radical,
que se presentó cuando pasamos de
aumentar la utilidad a disminuirla,
en la psicología de las personas,
acerca de lo que la moralidad nos exige,
en realidad está recogiendo
una diferencia forzada.
Pasemos a nuestro último caso.
En nuestro último caso
alguien obtiene 100
unidades de felicidad
y otros 100 obtienen 1 unidad cada uno.
Hay 200 unidades de felicidad.
O el Acto 6 en el que alguien pierde
5,000 unidades de felicidad,
pero otras 100 personas reciben
500 unidades cada quien,
de tal forma que se producen
45,000 unidades de felicidad.
En el Acto 1 a nadie le pasa nada malo,
pero el total de unidades de
felicidad es solamente de 200;
o en el Acto 6, donde una
persona sufre demasiado,
pero el total de unidades de
felicidad es 45,000.
Ok. Abrimos la votación con
10, 9, 8, 7, 6 segundos
y veamos los resultados
de esta pregunta.
Bien.
Ya vi la mayoría de sus
respuestas a la lectura
del caso de Omelas que sirve de
base para este caso,
y parece que la mayoría piensa que
el sufrimiento de una persona
no es algo que la moralidad nos exija,
aunque se incremente la
utilidad en general.
Como saben, el cuento de Omelas
habla de una sociedad
donde hay una comunidad de personas
y cada una tiene miles de
unidades de utilidad.
Son muy felices con su forma de vida.
Pero esa sociedad es así solamente
porque hay un niño encerrado
y su sufrimiento permite que el
resto de la sociedad sea feliz.
En la historia, cuando los niños
alcanzan la edad adulta
van a ver al niño que sufre.
Y la mayoría regresan a su comunidad
conscientes de esto, influidos por esto,
pero están dispuestos a tolerarlo.
Unos cuantos, al ver esto, abandonan
esa sociedad por completo.
Ahora, quiero que piensen a la
luz de su respuesta
de hace unos minutos acerca de
qué exige la moralidad
en algunas cosas que parecen tener
la estructura del cuento de Omelas.
Supongo que en algún punto de los
últimos 18 años más o menos,
alguien les ha revelado el secreto
de que el placer derivado
de comer carne depende, al igual
que la felicidad de Omelas,
del sacrificio de una gran
cantidad de animales no humanos.
Supongo que habrán notado la
semana pasada y antepasada,
cuando el campus estaba nevado,
que se abrían caminos
para que ustedes pudieran
llegar a sus clases
y esto dependía de que una gran
cantidad de personas,
cuyas vidas son un poco difíciles,
se levantaran de madrugada a limpiar,
aunque el trabajo fuera muy pesado e
hiciera un frío terrible.
Confío en que alguien ya les
ha revelado el secreto
de que la ropa que usan,
gracias a la cual sienten cierto placer,
en la mayoría de los
casos está producida
bajo condiciones muy parecidas a
la historia de Omelas,
concretamente bajo
explotación infantil.
De hecho, supongo que la mayoría
de ustedes son conscientes
de que la estructura del mundo moderno
tiene un parecido espeluznante
con la historia de Omelas.
La posibilidad de prosperidad
en el primer mundo
es de muchas maneras una consecuencia
de una estructura injusta con
respecto al tercer mundo.
Muchos de ustedes respondieron
que este tipo de estructura
es por lo menos esquemáticamente
aceptable por la moral.
Y la pregunta es: ¿qué
está pasando ahí?
Le Guin sugiere en su
historia que ustedes,
como estudiantes universitarios,
están justo en la edad en la
que darse cuenta de esto
podría causarles un efecto profundo.
Le Guin dice que tras haber sido
expuestos a este tipo de hechos:
"a menudo los jóvenes se van a casa
llorando o llenos de rabia
cuando han visto al niño que sufre
por el bien de su sociedad,
cuando se han enfrentado a
esta terrible paradoja.
Esto puede inquietarlos
durante semanas o años.
Pero conforme pasa el tiempo,
comienzan a darse cuenta
de que aunque el niño fuera liberado
no aprovecharía su libertad,
tendría un minúsculo y vago
placer de cariño y comida,
sin duda, pero poco más".
Una cosa interesante de la literatura,
a diferencia de la filosofía,
es que les permite interpretar
qué es lo que pasa.
La cuestión fundamental
de esta historia
es determinar si la frase
"Pero conforme pasa el tiempo,
comienzan a darse cuenta
de que aunque el niño fuera liberado
no aprovecharía su libertad,
tendría un minúsculo y vago
placer de cariño y comida,
sin duda, pero poco más"
es verdadera o si es un tipo
de racionalización
que ofrece el reconocimiento de
la propia comodidad.
Ella continúa explicando, tal
vez protestando demasiado,
diciendo lo siguiente: "se ha
degradado y entorpecido demasiado
para reconocer la auténtica felicidad.
Ha tenido miedo por tanto tiempo que
nunca podrá librarse de él.
Sus costumbres son muy burdas
para responder al trato humano".
De hecho, piensen en los
argumentos de llevar la democracia
a países donde no existe la democracia.
"Después de tanto tiempo,
puede sentirse desdichado
sin las paredes a su alrededor
protegiéndolo, sin la oscuridad para
los ojos, sin su propio
excremento para sentarse en él.
Las lágrimas de los jóvenes,
ante la amarga injusticia,
se secan cuando empiezan a percibir la
terrible justicia de la realidad
y acaban aceptándola".
No sé cuál de las dos lecturas
que propuse hacer del caso de
Le Guin es la correcta.
¿Está intentando argumentar o
ayudarles a reconocer
que el sentimiento inicial de
rabia ante el hecho
de que su bienestar depende del
sufrimiento de los demás
es una respuesta inmadura a una
estructura inevitable
de la injusticia en el mundo?
¿O está sugiriendo que al pensar así
están dejando ir su única
posibilidad de comportamiento moral,
es decir, en el momento que se
enfrentan a la injusticia
y lloran o sienten rabia
están en la oposición de
llevar esto a sus vidas?
No obstante, sugiere que vivir sus vidas
con los ojos abiertos al hecho
de que su bienestar
depende del sufrimiento de los otros
es obligatorio moralmente.
Continúa: "Tal vez sus
lágrimas y su rabia,
su intento de generosidad y la
aceptación de su propia impotencia,
son la verdadera fuente del
esplendor de sus vidas.
Saben que ellos, al igual que el
niño, no son libres"
que viven en un mundo de
interdependencia mutua.
"Conocen la compasión.
Gracias a su conciencia del
sufrimiento en el mundo,
gracias a ese niño son tan
amables con sus niños.
Saben que si el niño desdichado
no estuviera ahí
lloriqueando en la
oscuridad",
si no contáramos con los
recursos que permiten
que el primer mundo
prospere como lo hace,
"el otro niño, el flautista, no
podría tocar esa alegre música".
Todas las cosas de las que
nos beneficiamos,
la majestuosidad de esta
universidad, no estarían aquí.
"No habría música alegre mientras
los bellos y jóvenes jinetes
hacen fila para participar en
la carrera bajo el sol
de la primera mañana del verano".
Quiero dejarles esta idea como
una de las muchas cosas
que podemos extraer del cuento de
Omelas y como una introducción
de lo que implica hacer una
afirmación como la que hace Mill.
En la siguiente clase hablaremos,
en el contexto de Kant, de algunas
críticas sistemáticas
que se ofrecen sobre el marco
utilitario extraídas
de los escritos de Bernard Williams
y de nuestra alternativa
que se ofrece en los
escritos de Immanuel Kant.
Nos vemos el martes.